We’re directors of
our life. Every morning,
you call action.
If the thing you want
to do is direct a film,
well then, child, you’re
going to see me direct a film.
Action!
But if you don’t
want to direct a film,
still watch.
Because there are
strategies
that you can
use in any part
of your life where
you want to lead.
As a leader, one of the most powerful
things you can say is “I don’t know.”
“What do you think?”
“Teach me how to do this.”
You have to have
a ton of passion,
and authenticity,
so that the people who
are working with you
become ambassadors
for what you want to do.
They believe it too.
They feel it too.
I try to create space
for the people
people who are not
empowered to
speak in meetings.
Those quiet people,
they’re the folks
that have the most
ability and perspective
to observe everything.
The one thing
that we all have
in common is we
want to understand
how to do the
things that we want to do.
Look around you.
You have what
you need to start.
I’m Ava DuVernay,
and this is MasterClass.